Speaker 1: So this you absolutely have to see,
and I want to make sure I set this up for you,
so you understand the full scope of this. Months
ago, we started seeing this Partizan gap on
Speaker 2: COVID and the COVID rates
Speaker 1: were higher in Trump counties.
Hospitalizations were higher. Deaths have
gone now, almost three times higher in the
heavy Trump counties. Really bad places to
be for COVID. And maybe in some other ways
compared to the big Biden counties. Huge, huge
Speaker 2: gap. And I don't know if
Speaker 1: you guys remember, but I jokingly
said, how soon are they going to start saying?
Isn't it suspicious that you've got all these
unvaccinated Trump supporters getting COVID? Isn't
it suspicious that this is taking place? And of
Speaker 2: course, the reason
Speaker 1: would be simple
Well, the vaccine protects you.
The vaccine protects you to some degree from
Speaker 2: infection, and it protects you
to a greater degree from a
Speaker 1: serious illness, hospitalization and
Speaker 2: death. It was a joke.
Speaker 1: I joked that we would hear that,
but you can't joke about it anymore
because the joke has become a reality.
Radical right wing broadcaster Stu Peters has the
flu or COVID. He's not saying it seems he doesn't
know he's probably not even going to get tested,
and he is actually saying, I have this because it
was a targeted attack. They are targeting people
with cold, flu and COVID as a weapon to punish
Speaker 2: them for not
Speaker 1: getting vaccinated,
Speaker 2: apparently.
Speaker 1: Let's check out the clip you'll notice.
Speaker 2: At first, it's like almost
Speaker 1: too much for his guest, Deanna
Speaker 2: Lorraine, but then she
Speaker 1: quickly falls in line
with the insanity and even adds her
own craziness. You've got to see this.
Speaker 4: I wouldn't be surprised if this
so-called cold, the virus, the flu that I
have right now was a targeted attack on me. Do you
speculate that some of that might be going on as
well a targeted attack? Yeah, I mean, absolutely
like the bioweapon being released on you. This
the sociopath. Tony Fauci, when he he engineered
this taxpayer funded lab originated intentionally
released Wuhan China virus. I mean, that can
probably be used against people automatically.
I mean, people, Republicans, conservatives, talk
show host people being targeted with this virus,
right? I mean, don't you think we can paint these
100 percent? This paint the picture about, Oh,
well, Stu Peters got the coronavirus. He did
it to himself because he's not vaccinated.
Speaker 5: Exactly. Now one hundred percent, I
mean, we talked about last week with the World
Economic Forum launching this bubble gun that
you can just point a gun beepers, basically,
and someone gets a vaccine. I'm sure that
they have the power to target somebody to get
COVID. All of the very prominent Republicans and
people who have been outspoken against vaccines,
pastors, et cetera. Suddenly they come down
with a bad case of COVID, and it makes the news,
you know, anti-vax or anti-masker pastor comes
down with COVID. It's all too suspicious,
and I absolutely think people are being targeted.
Speaker 4: Well, they're going to have to try
harder than this because this thing,
whatever I have this week as hell.
Speaker 5: You're stronger than it.
Speaker 4: That's where I got I got
to wait a little bit of a stuffy nose now and a
little bit of a scratchy throat. What do you do?
Speaker 1: She's literally saying it.
She's saying it's suspicious. These people,
they speak out against vaccines.
Before you know it, they have COVID,
it must be that someone is infecting them on
purpose, folks. That's how it works. This is the
absolute epitome of the UN falsifiable argument.
If you don't get vaccinated and you get COVID,
it's not because you were unvaccinated and
totally unprotected. It's because they infected
Speaker 2: you as a punishment
Speaker 1: with a weaponized virus because
you didn't get vaccinated. That is an argument
that cannot be defeated with facts or reason
because they didn't reason their way into
it. Now also, it's funny that I mean,
Speaker 2: you know, quite frankly,
Speaker 1: who the hell is Stu Peters?
Is Stu Peters so important that anyone would
even bother to infect him deliberately?
Speaker 2: Like, who cares
Speaker 1: that Stu Peters is against vaccines?
Why would you even go and try to infect him? And
that's another aspect of conspiratorial thinking
that is very self-centered. It assumes a level
of self-importance that goes beyond any common
Speaker 2: sense or reason.
Speaker 1: You simply aren't that important a
player in this whole thing. And sometimes what
Speaker 2: pushes people, we've I mean,
Speaker 1: at this point, how much have we talked
about conspiracies and conspiratorial thinking
a ton? And there's so many
Speaker 2: aspects to this
Speaker 1: gullibility and, you know, all these
different things. Oftentimes when when you
believe you are a player in the whole thing.
The delusion is that you see yourself as so
Speaker 2: important as one of seven, eight
Speaker 1: billion people on this planet
that clearly they
Speaker 2: would be
targeting you or paying attention
Speaker 1: to what you're saying.
It's really quite simple. He caught a
virus against which he wasn't vaccinated.
Speaker 2: It might be
Speaker 1: COVID, and he seems to not
have gotten the COVID vaccine. It might be flu.
I'm guessing he also doesn't get the flu vaccine.
Speaker 2: That's it.
Speaker 1: He's at higher risk
because he didn't get
Speaker 2: vaccinated and it got
Speaker 1: him. There is no big mystery here.
But it always has to be more complicated,
partially by putting himself at the
Speaker 2: center of this grand
Speaker 1: conspiracy. And they are so close to
getting it. I mean, you know, Deanna Lorraine,
she actually says, you know, all these
unvaccinated people are getting sick. Well,
apply Occam's Razor. Maybe it's because the
vaccine really does protect you. Now she has
to stop short of that and instead go with the
more complicated explanation the unvaccinated
people. People are being targeted by those who
have weaponized the virus as a punishment for
not falling in line with vaccination,
and as I don't remember who it was now.
Speaker 2: What is it, Peter Bergen?
Speaker 1: I don't remember who came up with
this. You're not going to reason your way out of a
belief you didn't reason your way into, and we're
not going to reason people out of beliefs that
they didn't reason their ways into their way into.
Speaker 2: And that's exactly what is happening
Speaker 1: with Stu Peters right here.